let's say that I run a country or I run
a company I should say that is based
inside of the United States so this
right over here is my company maybe I
have some smokestacks of some kind so
that is my company and it makes a
million dollars in pre-tax profits 1
million dollars and this is before tax
so pre-tax profits and let's say that
the country that I'm in in the way I've
drawn it this is the United States let's
say at the time that I make those
pre-tax profits the corporate tax rate
is 35% 35% tax rate so it's pretty
straightforward to think about how much
taxes I would have to pay
I would pay 35% on this 1 million
dollars or essentially I would pay three
hundred fifty thousand dollars in taxes
three hundred and fifty thousand dollars
in taxes and I would have six hundred
fifty thousand left in profit so six
hundred and fifty thousand left in
profit now what I want to think about
let's say my company wants to get little
bit more creative about how it might
save on taxes so what it does is it
realizes that there's an island not too
far off the US coast and directory
several of them that has a substantive
ly lower tax rate and I'm just picking
it arbitrary but let's say it has a five
percent a five percent corporate tax
rate five percent tax rate so how can
this company which is physically or for
the most part based in this country
somehow benefit from this lower tax rate
that is happening offshore
well what they'll typically do is set up
another subsidiary one that this company
owns and controls but it is set up in
this little island nation so let's set
it up right over here so that's the
other company and what I'll do is it'll
tend to give it maybe oftentimes it'll
give it some intellectual property maybe
patents trademarks things like that so
it gets all of the intellectual property
of the parent company so given given the
intellectual the intellectual property
and then what it can say is well and
this is owned this is owned by the
parent entity so I'll draw a little
dotted line here it's owned and
controlled by this country this company
that's based in the
u.s. and what they'll say is look we
don't have a million dollar pre-tax
profit anymore because we need
essentially license the use of these
tray of this of this intellectual
property whether it's trademarks
copyrights patents we got to pay this
entity right over here some amount of
money to use that intellectual property
so let's say that they say we're going
to pay them we're going to pay them I
don't know eight hundred thousand
dollars and this is essentially transfer
pricing in theory one there's there
should be a way of deciding what is the
fair rate for that intellectual property
but oftentimes that intellectual
property is fairly unique so it's hard
to determine a market rate which really
just leaves this company decide it for
itself so let's say let's decide let's
go into that reality where instead of
this reality this company before it had
a million in pre-tax profits but now
it's paying 800,000 in royalties and
licensing to this entity right over here
so out of that 1 million you have
800,000 going offshore you have 8
800,000 goes offshore and so the real
pre-tax profit for this company now
based on accounting for it this way
based on paying this subsidiary that's
offshore for use of the intellectual
property the company now has six hundred
K or I should say 200k in pre-tax
profits 200k so that was before the
licensing now this is after the
licensing this is the new pre-tax number
this is the new pre-tax number and so in
the u.s. it would only pay 35% of the
$200,000 instead of paying three hundred
fifty thousand dollars in taxes it would
now pay so it's no longer three hundred
fifty in taxes 35% of two hundred case
70 K in taxes 70 K in taxes and the US I
guess you could say parent company would
show a profit of two hundred K minus the
70 K of one hundred and thirty thousand
dollars so one hundred and thirty
thousand I would call it net profit we
could say post tax post tax profit and
then this character right over here
let's say it has very minimal cost let's
say has no cost for a simplification it
would have some to do some
paperwork it would all of this would
essentially be profit and you know maybe
have a few thousand dollars in cost but
we won't we'll ignore that for now so
all of this would be its pre-tax profit
it would have to pay five percent of it
five percent in taxes to this to this
country right over here so five percent
of eight hundred thousand is forty
thousand dollars so it would pay forty
thousand in taxes to the government of
this island right over here and then it
would be left with the remainder seven
hundred sixty thousand dollars so it
would have seven hundred and sixty
thousand I guess you could call that in
its net profit after paying taxes net
net profit so you can see here the
company saved substantially on taxes it
paid seventy thousand in the US and
forty thousand abroad so it paid a total
of a hundred ten thousand in taxes
versus the three hundred fifty thousand
it would have had to pay if it was based
purely purely in the United States so
you might say hey this is a great thing
companies you know why even have an
eight hundred thousand transfer price
why not do a million and obviously if
you do it a little bit too ridiculously
it'll get more and more scrutiny so
there's some balancing influence there
and obviously if there is a market for
this intellectual property or that type
of intellectual property or if you are
licensing to other people that might
dictate what this is but you might say
well why not do this night and day
well the question is you now have this
profit and it might be in the form of
cash we go into other videos in more
depth when it might not be but you have
essentially this profit but you won't be
able to get it back into the United
States without paying a tax on it so if
you want to get it back the United
States and that's actually the check the
reason why we do tax repatriation of
funds is so that companies can't do this
night and day essentially transfer
profits abroad and then bring the cash
back in in order to close this loophole
that's why the repatriation of this
funds are the repatriation of these
funds are actually taxed and I'll let
you think about and it obviously depends
on what the transfer prices are and
things like that
but essentially in order what what this
tax rate would have to be in order for a
company to come out neutral but and
there's other ways to getting around it
and I'll
other videos later so this of ways that
this cache can be put to use and it
still is not actually taxed